hey David is the idea of impeaching
Trump over I'm not hearing very much
about it but at the same time supposedly
Jerry Nadler
is running an impeachment inquiry what
the hell is going on so listen here's
the answer I don't care either way and
what I mean by that is we should know if
there's going to be an impeachment
inquiry or not but I've said before at
this point the possibility of the
impeachment inquiry is doing nothing for
the left it's a distraction okay if
anything it's hurting the left internal
debates about should we do an
impeachment inquiry or should we not do
an impeachment inquiry Pelosi says no
and Nadler says yes or whoever says yes
no whatever and they get into these
arguments that's how you lose okay
option one start the impeachment inquiry
right away I'm fine with that I think
that that would be damaging to Donald
Trump it would take away some of the
power of Donald Trump's narrative
setting ability within the media that
would be fine
decide we're going to table the
impeachment inquiry until for example
November 1st not 2019 or February 1st
2020 or whenever Democrats say this is
when the impeachment inquiry will be
most damaging to Donald Trump great I'm
fine with that as well yes it's playing
politics oh no it's okay
if that's the idea that we could do more
damage to Trump by starting the
impeachment inquiry at some later point
let's do it
or no impeachment inquiry let's just win
2020 and put our efforts on that I'm
fine with that as well so I don't know
if the idea of impeaching Trump is over
or more accurately doing the impeachment
inquiry which would be the first step
the the sort of pre impeachment inquiry
I don't really care as long as everybody
is on the same page and we understand
what the impeachment inquiry would lead
to and what it would not lead to the
impeachment inquiry would lead to making
public a lot of the content of the
Moller report which most people haven't
read that's good it will damage Trump it
will lead to media stories about the
impeachment inquiry that's good that's
time that is not being manipulated by
Donald Trump and other good things the
impeachment inquiry will not lead to
removal of Donald Trump via an
impeachment conviction in the Senate
it just won't okay so as long as we
understand what it will and won't do I'm
fine with doing it now doing it in six
months or doing it not at all but we've
got to stop going back and forth about
it and in that sense I'm not displeased
that discussions of impeachment has sort
of evaporated meanwhile though based on
Trump's erratic behavior over the last
10 days or so since we started and since
ended our show vacation more and more
discussions of removal under the 25th
amendment for being unfit to serve have
surfaced and are perpetuating themselves
in social media also don't know that
that's going to go anywhere but I'm
totally fine with not pursuing
impeachment against Donald Trump and I'm
completely fine with doing it as well